avant de commencer un petit
avertissement pour vous signaler que
cette vidéo est la deuxième partie d'un
projet fait en partenariat avec nos
universités et la région pays de la
loire pour expliquer le quotidien des
chercheurs en sociologie dans la
première partie on a exploré le
fonctionnement du monde scientifique
auquel prennent part les sociologues et
dans cette partie on va soulever le
capot de la discipline pour comprendre
comment on fait vraiment de la
sociologie alors la sociologie c'est
avant tout une science empirique ça ça
veut dire que le sociologue il doit
aller sur le terrain pour récolter des
données à analyser globalement il ya
deux grands types de données
premièrement il ya les données
qualitatives ça ça va être de
l'observation par exemple ou alors des
entretiens qu on va faire avec les
enquêtés généralement ces deux
entretiens assez long où on va assez
profondément dans les choses et de
l'autre côté il ya ce qu'on appelle les
données quantitatives ça c'est quand on
va s'appuyer plutôt sur des
questionnaires et sur des données
chiffrées évidemment le plus souvent les
chercheurs il croise les deux approches
pour être plus pertinent on va commencer
par discuter des recherches
quantitatives avec le maître de
conférences tristan poullaouec il
travaille entre autres sur les
aspirations scolaires notamment des
classes populaires et depuis son travail
de thèse il a l'habitude de travailler
avec des données chiffrées donc je lui
demande de nous expliquer d'où viennent
les données quantitatives ben on a un
appareil statistique en france qui est
assez développée depuis longtemps mais
surtout dans les années 60 début
fort mouvement de d'installation de
service statistique dans les ministères
et donc ces données et en public ayant
un intérêt public elles savent pas
seulement à aider les gouvernants à
décider eh bien elles peuvent être
restitués au public et notamment aux
chercheurs donc actuellement l'insee met
à disposition pas seulement des tableaux
et des graphiques mais des fichiers
sources ouvrez les données individuelles
anonymisées
et les chercheurs les étudiants peuvent
s'en emparer pour refaire des
traitements statistiques
donc voilà de la statistique publique
qui fournit beaucoup de données et puis
dans certaines situations les chercheurs
les enseignants chercheurs peuvent aussi
produire leurs propres données
quantitatives
bon
souvent il faut un budget quand même
parce qu' une enquête quantitative sur
un grand nombre de l'enquêté ça peut
coûter un peu d'argent
quand il faut faire d envoi par la poste
quand il faut faire du porte à porte
quand il faut faire de la saisie et
c'est tout ça ça ça mobilise un travail
de l'équipe est rarement les budgets
permettent de de l'envisager sereinement
ça arrive mais c'est quand même pas si
fréquent l'impression qu'on voit un peu
parfois en double problème pour le
public et bien sûr de parfois soit de la
trop grande résidence du chiffre comme
quoi ce serait l'élément de preuve par
excellence soit au contraire la méfiance
extrême du chiffre de type les chiffres
on leur fait dire ce qu'on veut du coup
comment comment en fait concrètement
quand on travaille en sociologie donc en
fait dissipées un petit peu ce problème
là je vais prendre un point de vie des
enseignants parce que c'est un
typiquement le genre de difficultés
qu'on a avec des étudiants de premier
cycle ces deux attitudes sont aussi
infondées en réalité parce qu'elle
n'aide pas à comprendre comment s'est
fabriqué une donnée quantitative c'est
ça la bonne voie un creuset c'est de
décider de refaire l'histoire de la
production de la donner pour mieux
comprendre
ses limites les conditions d usage mais
aussi pourquoi elle est utile et
quelques à la porte alain desrosières
que j'utilise souvent aussi dans
l'enseignement disait parfois il
faudrait pas à donner un chiffre mais
toujours en donner deux trois souvent en
fait dans le débat public on vous donne
une quantité c'est un nombre absolu
souvent qui fait impressionnant il ya
trente mille étudiants qui demandent
l'aide alimentaire oui c'est beaucoup
mais alors est-ce que c'est plus
qu'avant est-ce que c'est moins qu'avant
parce que c'est plus que dans d'autres
pays en fait pour bien faire il faut il
faut pas s'arrêter à ce nombre absolu
qui est un peu impressionnant il faut le
mettre en relation avec d'autres donc
les données à doivent pas être seulement
brut mais elle doit être relative
comparée
et puis il faut essayer aussi de
d'expliquer comment on a compté ça voilà
par exemple avec les étudiants là on on
a mené une enquête par questionnaire sur
leurs pratiques alimentaires c'est pour
ça que j'ai cet exemple en tête on leur
a demandé est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
recours à l'aide alimentaire 10% au mois
de novembre là dans huit universités en
france c'était pas seulement pendant la
pandémie c'est un phénomène structurel
qui existent encore
et on leur avait aussi proposé comme
modalités de réponse
non on me l'a refusé à nouveau de 3% et
puis troisième modalités qui était non
mais j'en aurais eu besoin et ça c'était
une proposition des étudiants et j'ai
trouvé que c'était très astucieux parce
que là on a pu repérer ce qu'on appelle
le non recours c'est à dire l'expression
d'un besoin mais qui pour différentes
raisons n'a pas été jusqu'à la demande
est bien quand on fait la somme de ces
trois besoins on arrive à 30% qu'ils
soient ont eu recours alimentaire ou
alors ne l'ont pas fait mais on aura eu
besoin 30% c'est pas rien est ce que ça
montre aussi toute l'importance de la
construction du questionnaire en fait
oui pour avoir
ce questionnaire a été élaboré donc par
un collectif d'enseignants et
d'étudiants dans huit universités on l'a
testé alors justement comment ça se
passe parce que j'imagine que c'est pas
du premier coup on se réunit on fait un
questionnaire et ça y est on l'envoie à
10000 personnes alors très souvent en
fait on commence par des entretiens
exploratoires on va pas chercher les
réponses des enquêtés mais plutôt leurs
questions on va essayer de discuter avec
eux sur le thème de l' enquête pour voir
qu'est ce qui les anime qu'est ce qu'ils
ont en tête de quoi ils ont envie de
parler finalement est-ce que si on fait
pas cette étape là le risque c'est
d'imposer une problématique souvent qui
vient d'en haut souvent un peu experte
et qui va pas faire sens voilà l'erreur
à ne pas faire c'est de vous poser
vraiment la question d'experts ce que
vous pensez que par exemple la france
doit sortir de l'espace de schengen
poser cette question d'experts à une
population qui ne connais pas du tout le
problème
c'est s'exposer à des hésitations des
non réponses
et même pire que ça à des gens qui vont
répondre pour faire plaisir à
l'enquêteur pour garder la face nous
dira oui oui ou non non non mais s'en
séparer navy informés donc quand on
prépare un questionnaire on on commence
par faire des entretiens exploratoires
et c'est à partir souvent des mots des
enquêtés qu'on va trouver des formules
qu'on a envie de tester et puis après on
fait un première la premier
questionnaire test et c'est seulement
après qu'on se lance pour de vrai quoi
alors comme je voulais dit les maîtres
de conférences il donne aussi des cours
et l'enseignement représente même une
partie non négligeable de leur emploi du
temps j'ai pu filmer tristan poullaouec
faire cours à des étudiants de l2 avec
lesquels il travaille sur la fameuse
base de données dont on a discuté sur
l'alimentation et il leur apprend en
sortir des jolis graphiques pour mettre
en évidence des relations comme par
exemple une corrélation négative entre
le fait de manger bio et le fait d'avoir
recours à l'aide alimentaire même si les
élèves sont un peu timides en présence
de la caméra déjà avant d'aller plus
loin est ce que ça donne des résultats
intéressants est ce que ça valait la
peine de faire ça qu'est ce que vous
constatez
personne ne veut
faire entendre le son de sa voix dans la
vidéo de boris
regarder ce qu'on constate quand même
c'est qu'il ya une espèce de relation
qui se dessine comme ça - ont recours à
l'aide alimentaire plus on retrouve une
consommation bio plus fréquentes où on y
venait de tout à l'heure qui est un peu
cliché elle a quand même une petite base
empirique voilà donc ils ont tous le
même matériau la même problématique
générale mais après ils choisissent une
dimension du questionnaire ça peut être
ici voilà les étudiants qui vivent
couvre donc une sous population ça peut
être une pratique là qui vont travailler
sur
ceux qui ont un régime vegan par exemple
et à la fin ils meurent data compte
rendu un peu comme ça l'est les quatre
pages qu'on trouve dans les publications
de l'insee insee première population et
sociétés aussi à l'ined donc on place la
barre assez haut mais pour leur montrer
que c'est à leur portée en fait que dès
lors qu'ils savent faire des tableaux
croisés c'est déjà largement assez pour
rendre compte d'une enquête et toucher
un public un peu plus large et voilà
pouvoir dire à ses parents va regarder
ses terres des choses
c'est quoi la question vous est posée à
partir des données nous on axe sur le
couple donc comment ils se différencient
des étudiants qui vivent pas en compte
et ce qu'ils sont égales dans le
pratique de l'alimentation anses qui
cuisinent pareil les courses et à ce
qu'ils mangent plus bio est ce qu'ils
vont plus consommé d'alcool et on va
essayer de voir des différences entre
ceux qui vivent en couple et ce qu'ils
pensent
ce qu'ils sont en couple là ils sont à
67 % ils ont cuisiné eux mêmes leurs
repas qu'ils mangent et alors que ceux
qui sont en gros ce que 51% et la
plupart du coup il c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui remet à cuisiner pour eux
ouais on mange plus quelque chose qu'on
a cuisiné que ce soit
fini avec son copain ou sa copine ou bon
du coup quand on parle de variables
quantitative le travail du sociologue ça
va principalement être du traitement de
données derrière un ordinateur on
suivant bien les règles de la
significativité statistique
mais bien évidemment ce n'est qu'une
petite partie du travail du sociologue
qui a également recours aux méthodes
qualitatives là n'a plus le choix il
doit sortir de son bureau pour aller
directement sur le terrain avec son
dictaphone et son carnet d'observation
comme on dit que le sociologue va faire
de l'observation directe il faut bien
avoir en tête que c'est pas aussi simple
parce que il ya certaines personnes
certains métiers ou même certains
milieux qui sont assez réticents à
l'idée de se faire observer par des
sociologues du coup la première étape du
travail pour le sociologue c'est bien
souvent d'essayer de convaincre ans
d'enquêté de bien vouloir se laisser
observé mais même quelques sociologues
arrive à accéder à son terrain que ces
enquêtes et l'acceptent qui viennent les
observer ou acceptent des entretiens
tout n'est pas encore gagné parce que
les enquêtés seront souvent une image un
peu faussée ce que vient dire le
sociologue et du coup ils peuvent se
montrer méfiant et ne pas vouloir lui
confier certaines choses parce que ils
le voient pas forcément comme un allié
souvent on les identifie à des
journalistes à des psychologues en tout
cas la position de sociologues dans le
rapport d' enquête et pas toujours bien
identifiés et du coup ça ça peut donner
lieu à des conditions d' enquête un peu
faussé un peu bizarre et du coup ce le
rôle du chercheur ça va être sans cesse
d'essayer de rassurer c'est enquêter
pour qu'ils puissent leur confier parce
que nous ce qui nous intéresse pas c'est
leur expérience leur façon de penser
leur vie et s'ils se montrent trop
méfiants mais en fait on va pas réussir
à recueillir du matériau vraiment
intéressant pour notre enquête
sociologique c'est un point que j'ai pu
aborder assez longuement avec elijah
amer qui est en quatrième année de thèse
à l'université de nantes et qui est un
terrain assez originale car elle étudie
le nez au protestantisme évangélique
alors là vous avez peut-être en tête des
shows américains avec des pasteurs plein
aux as qui soigne locaux vides à travers
leurs télévisions quand
et bien merci mec heureusement que tu es
là j'ai pas ce qu'on aurait fait sans
toi non je rigole mais bien sûr il faut
pas rester sur cette image le nez au
protestantisme évangélique est loin
d'être aussi caricaturale et c'est une
branche du christianisme très vivace qui
se développe partout dans le monde et
notamment en algérie ou qu'elles ont
déjà fait son terrain dans un petit
village de tradition musulmane où les
évangélistes se sont développées jusqu'à
convertir 50% de la population plus
particulièrement pardon je m'intéresse
aux effets de la conversion sur les
femmes plutôt les femmes kabyles donc la
cabine est ce une région berbérophone en
algérie
alors vous imaginez bien que pour ce
type de sujet l'accès au terrain c'est
un point absolument crucial est que
luciana une porte d'entrée privilégiée
car il s'agit du village de ses
grands-parents et qu'elle parle
elle-même berbère même si elle m'a avoué
avoir parfois recrutés sa famille comme
assistant de recherche pour retranscrire
certaines nuances linguistique
rencontrés dans ces entretiens tu te
présentes comme sociologue non pas de ça
alors je me alors j c'est hyper
compliqué alors ça dépend à qui je
m'adresse quand je m'adresser aux
pasteurs je disais je suis sociologue je
réalise une thèse de sociologie parce
que c'est enfin il comprenait ce que
c'était et c'est quand je parlais avec
les villageois qui sont pour la plupart
beaucoup de femmes qui n'ont pas été à
l'école et qui
ne maîtrisant plus que le berbère donc
parfois c'était un peu compliqué tu vois
leur dire sociologue
elle ne comprenait pas ce que c'est en
fait je disais c'est pour l'école mais
la manière dont j'ai été perçu par eux
étaient complètement différent de la
manière dont moi je me présentais
souvent en fait ils voyaient comme une
journaliste
tu vas pas enfin je croisais des
villageois qui me disait ah c'est toi la
journaliste qu'est venu interroger les
chrétiens
et au début alors je disais non non je
suis pas journaliste et caetera et après
j'ai fini par laisser tomber parce que
je me suis dit que c'était bon tant pis
on le voit comme une journaliste j'en
suis pas eu d expliquer à chaque fois
que c'était que voilà mais j'ai à chaque
fois jusqu'à maintenant je continue à
être associé à la journaliste qui vient
c'est juste pour des questions parce que
c'est important la façon dont le
sociologue est perçu sur son terrain jeu
typiquement il ya certains terrains ou
être présente et assimilés ou vu comme
un journaliste ça peut fermer des portes
plus tôt que les ouvrir là sur ton
terrain j'ai l'impression que c'est le
cas où finalement en fait il n'y a pas
spécialement de jugement ça dépend des
deux des acteurs que j'avais en face de
moi les pasteurs il était hyper méfiant
par exemple il refusait que j'enregistre
les entretiens que je faisais avec eux
il y avait beaucoup de langue de bois il
y avait franchement j'avais du mal je
ramène pour les entretiens avec eux a
essayé de leur faire dire des choses
parce qu'ils étaient hyper méfiant quoi
pour mais cette espèce de doute autour
de qui je suis vraiment quoi qu'est-ce
que je fais qu'est ce que je veux en
plus ils se sentent persécutés voilà ils
ont un discours très victimaire on nous
laisse pas pratiquer notre religion paix
dans un pays à majorité musulmane et
cetera en plus ils savent que ma famille
était musulmane donc mais tu es avec
nous tu es pas avec nous tu es contre
nous pas contre nous qu'est ce que tu
veux vraiment donc avec les pasteurs il
ya eu
il était un peu méfiant mais par contre
les fidèles donc les villageois pas du
tout et a réussi à contourner cette
difficulté où ça reste ça qui alors
quand je rencontrais le pasteur du
village lui là j'ai finalement réussi à
le mettre en confiance ils étaient un
peu moins méfiants parce que du coup je
revenais les voir plusieurs fois mais
pas tous je pense notamment à l'époque
c'était malade qui a été le président de
l'église protestante d'algérie lui j'ai
jamais réussi à le mettre en confiance
ils voulaient pas que j'assiste au culte
aucun pasteur ne m'avait interdit
la présence inculte lui voulait pas il
voulait pas que je l'enregistré il
voulait pas que je passe trop de temps
dans l'église par exemple je voulais
visiter le lieu ils voulaient pas il
avait été lui il avait été hyper méfiant
il est resté méfiant à chaque fois que
je le rencontrais ça bougeait pas quoi
comme on le voit certains terrains sont
donc difficile d'accès mais c'est l'un
des avantages de la thèse que d'avoir le
temps de rester assez longuement sur le
terrain pour mieux s'y faire connaître
et on gagne ainsi en crédibilité au fur
et à mesure que l'on enquête c'est
essentiel parce que c'est de l'addition
de tous les points de vue rencontré que
pourra se dégager le savoir sociologique
comme le disait souvent le sociologue
américain ray plate cucs il n'y a rien
que je sache qu'au moins un des membres
de ce groupe ne sache également mais
comme je sais ce qu'ils savent tous j'en
sais plus que n'importe lequel d'entre
eux ce temps long permet également
d'observer des évolutions au cours de l'
enquête comme l'expliqué joseph godefroy
à propos des quelques enquêtes et qu'il
a pu revoir plusieurs fois certains ça
fait cinq ans qu'ils sont sur instagram
évidemment ils ont expérimenté des
choses que ce que je rencontre qui sont
pour leur première année en contact avec
des marques et bien vont pas voir ou
verront peut-être plus tard c'est aussi
pour ça que les quelques jeux zinc j'ai
pu voir nager un peu longitudinal c'est
très précieux me réjouis de voir naître
d'une année à l'autre déjà ah mais oui
non mais en fait c'est des gros cons je
vais plus travailler avec eux mêmes dans
les discours vais l'avouer tu vois je
dis je veux plus travailler avec eux
alors qu'au départ on n'avait pas
forcément un champ lexical qui du
travail ça aussi c'est un des points
des gros points de mes conclusions c'est
que même lorsqu'il la marchandisation
qu'elle est explicite que pour certains
c'est évident qu'ils sont au service des
entreprises pour eux ça reste du loisir
et vont utiliser le discours de la
passion comme on peut le voir le
sociologue n'est donc jamais un élément
complètement extérieur au terrain qui
l'étudient c'est quelque chose que
souligner des à bourdieu évidemment le
rapport d'enquêté un rapport social et
la personne interrogée à l'idée du
statut social de la personne qu'il
interroge donc de ses goûts de ses
préférences et il a peur d'être jugé par
l'interrogateur du coup il y a un double
travail à faire de la part du sociologue
c'est à la fois de mettre en confiance
ses interlocuteurs mais aussi de garder
la distance nécessaire à l'analyse
scientifique
c'est un point qui a été bien discutée
par la sociologue martina avandia dans
un article de 2008 appelait comment
faire de l'ethnographie quand on n'aime
pas ces indigènes elle faisait son
terrain de stage auprès du parti de la
ligue du nord en italie qui serait un
peu l'équivalent du r n en france et
devait donc resté de marbre en écoutant
ses enquêtes et dire des trucs turbo
racisme par exemple lorsqu'elle écoute
une mère désespérée lui raconter que sa
fille partir en erasmus en angleterre se
met à sortir avec un musulman
pakistanais
elle doit s'efforcer de feindre la
compassion en omettant bien qu'elle
partage elle même sa vie avec un
marocain si on imagine bien que ces
questions de distance au terrain sont
cruciales dans les cas où l'on doit
presque se créer une nouvelle identité
elles le sont aussi lorsqu'on en quête
des milieux qui nous sont proches et
paradoxalement c'est peut être même là
que la distance réflexive et la plus
importante pour faire un travail de
qualité tu peux te retrouver avec des
individus en entretien avec qui ça va se
passer est extrêmement bien c'est à dire
que tu te retrouves face à un entretien
rêver tu commences à lens et ont enquêté
sur quelque chose il va s'en saisir il
va aller dans des directions il va
proposer des analyses sans avoir à
intervenir trop l'enquêté va fournir un
certain nombre de choses bourdieu avait
dit attention hasna parce qu'en fait ce
que ça reflète cette sorte de connivence
en entretien c'est une trop forte
proximité sociale et donc il faut être
aussi extrêmement vigilant parce que
dans un entretien il s'agit certes de
recueillir la parole d'un enquêter sur
son parcours sur art etc mais il s'agit
d'être celui qui est l'analyse
quand tu es à face à quelqu'un qui va te
proposer des analyses de son propre
parcours
il faut tout de même être vigilant parce
que toi ton travail c'est pas forcément
de reprendre les analystes ont inquiété
là tu fais autre chose encore une fois
c'est un point que j'ai pu aborder avec
un peu plus de détails avec florent
police il est en première année de thèse
à l'université de nantes et il étudie
les mobilisations collectives en milieu
rural et plus précisément un collectif
qui s'est formée contre la mise en place
d'un méthaniseur industriels il se
présente bien sûr son terrain comme un
sociologue mais aussi comme un militant
et il me dit qu'il partage lui même la
cause de ces enquêtes et je lui demande
donc comment on fait pour garder une
distance critique nécessaire à la
sociologie quand on étudie un mouvement
auquel on adhère est-ce que tu as une
attention particulière du coup à
l'objectivation que tu dois avoir là
dessus je suppose que tu portes un
intérêt particulier est ce qu est ce que
tu as des méthodes des garde-fous
justement pour pour éviter d'avoir des
biais méthodologiques
ouais ouais complètement c'est vrai que
ça c'est un point ce site avait pas posé
la question mais c'était sûr talent et
la pause et je l'aurais je l'aurais
soulevé est en fait une question assez
classique le 6 1 voilà la question de la
réflexivité du sociologue bon évidemment
les classiques
dürckheim on met de côté ses prêts
notion weber neutralité axiologique mais
bon faut pas oublier ça c'est pareil que
la neutralité axiologique c'est aussi
utilisé par certains sociologues parce
que j c'est un champ où il ya des
rapports de pouvoir comme un argument
politique or la sociologie la neutralité
axiologique c'est pas simplement se dire
ok moi je suis là je fais un entretien
avec vous je vous observe et je suis
complètement extérieur à la situation
qui est en train de se passer et voilà
je ne me prend absolument pas part je
n'ai aucune influence sur 7 sur cette
situation or quand tu es là en train de
discuter avec les gens tu as forcément
une influence sur l'interaction qui en
train de se dérouler donc donc tu influe
nécessairement sur donc c'est ça tout
l'enjeu de la posture réflexive et moi
dans mon cas c'est comment
voilà en tant que chercheur est adhérent
à la cause que j'étudie
comment concrètement j'opère ce moment
de d'autoanalyse de réflexion sur
moi-même et sur ma posture alors après
évidemment c'est tout un tas de ya tout
un tas technique j'ai évidemment le
carnet de terrain qui est central où on
note absolument toutes les interactions
qu'on a et cetera on note aussi la
manière dont on a réagi à tel moment
comment on s'est senti dans
l'interaction et moi en effet ça m'est
arrivé de me poser la question de me
mettre des notes sur mon carnet de
terrain par exemple - s'engager dans la
discussion est moins prendre
l'initiative des parce qu'au début c'est
vrai que quand je suis arrivé bon il
fallait que j'affirme aussi ma posture
de sympathisants à la lutte mais mais
bon c'est vrai que je me suis quand même
noté l'a vraiment dans le cadre des
discussions et cède quand même de parler
un peu moins quoi de ton avis et c est
là mais là pour pas rentrer dans un
rapport vraiment de discussion de
militants à militants aussi tu vois on
parle de syndicats mentionne la cgt ou
la cfdt hélas les personnes parfois ils
ont des réactions différentes en moi il
y en a certains c'est la cfdt un machin
et là moi je renchéris en mode ah oui
négocié le poids des chaînes et du coup
là ça permet de relancer la discussion
sur ce sujet et c'est bien mais tu le
fais en fonction de la réaction que tu
as voilà c'est ça voilà c'est ça mais
c'est vrai que mais c'est vrai voilà
c'est quand même ça le garde-fou c'est
me dire bon je veux pas produire le
discours de mme et enquêter par contre
tu vois là dans le cadre de réunions du
collectif voilà il parle stratégie de
com en fait là il m'arrive des fois de
de prendre la parole et dire ah ben moi
si vous voulez vous cherchez un article
en ligne je peux y avoir accès je peux
vous l'envoyer ou à huawei pour la mise
en page
je sais qu'il ya ça qui est très bien
pour faire comme ça si ça vous intéresse
vous file l'habitude voix c'est vraiment
des petits conseils qui montre que voilà
j'adhère à la côte mais par contre le
garde-fou c'est d'orienter quand même le
moins possible le discours politique
du collectif que j'enquête si on veut
sur le terrain il est donc primordial de
bien réfléchir à comment on se place à
la fois en tant que personne mais aussi
en tant que chercheur florian avait par
exemple fait le choix d'être en
immersion pendant un mois dans le
village qu'ils étudient pour pouvoir
s'en imprégner et enchaîner plus
facilement les entretiens et ben
maintenant il ne nous reste plus qu'à
aller voir pour de vrai comment ça se
passe sur un terrain de sociologie
là c'est le matin on va accompagner deux
sociologues sur le terrain ils sont en
train d'étudier l'école dans la grande
pluralité on y va
[Musique]
là on a rendez-vous devant la fac partie
on veut plus là on va faire deux heures
une heure de route on va aller un peu
dans la campagne donc là on a de la
chance de pouvoir aller véritablement
sur le terrain accompagner les
sociologues pour voir comment ça se
passe concrètement avec les inquiéter
[Musique]
avant d'arriver sur le terrain
proprement dit on profite donc du temps
de trajet pour en apprendre un peu plus
sur l'enquète qui est en train d'être
mené on travaille sur les difficultés
scolaires des enfants en milieu rural
donc c'est vraiment notre entrée de
départ c'est d'essayer de comprendre
comment les parents gèrent la scolarité
de leurs enfants et quelles ressources
ils peuvent mobiliser en fait alors le
problème c'est qu assez rapidement le
coc vie d'un rendu compliqué d'aller
enquêter dans les écoles et elles ont
réorienté leur terrain pour aller
interroger prioritairement le personnel
médical qui encadrent les enfants en
parallèle de l'école mais c'est laquelle
ont été confrontés à certains imprévus
assez vite
[Musique]
finalement qu'est tout des pratiques
pour résumer un peu ce que nous explique
sophie orange c'est que dans la grande
rue réalité les psychologues scolaires
et les orthophonistes sont très loin de
pouvoir répondre à toutes les demandes
de la part à la fois de l'école et de la
famille ce qui fait que les gens ont
recours à des acteurs comme des
hypnotiseurs des énergéticiens ou des
kinésiologues est en fait toute une
gamme de praticiens de médecine dite
alternative ou parallèles qui joue un
rôle très important soit en raison de
files d'attentes très longues sur les
praticiens conventionnel soit aussi
parfois par un mouvement de rejet
revendiqué dans une mouvance un peu
hâtive axe et ça c'est vraiment
passionnant parce qu'on a à faire un
élément qui n'était pas prévu
initialement et donc ça ça montre que le
terrain étudiée il est a priori ultra
riche d'enseignements il ya un autre
élément que je pense particulièrement
intéressant ça va être de voir comment
on construit une analyse sociologique à
partir de là parce que il faut pas
oublier que le sociologue c'est avant
tout un être humain qui doit faire très
attention au degré de distance qu'ils
gardent avec le terrain est l'objet
étudié
on se fait cueillir parce que en plus
comme ça touche mes lentilles sa touche
l'intime sur les enfants alors on pense
à nos enfants et à dire ah oui il faut
faire l'éducation
bienveillance
et bah merde moi je fais pas de soutien
bienveillant et après on nous dit non en
fait faut pas faire d' éducation bien
rire et en fait ça nous retourne ça et
c'est vrai que ça nous retombe quand
même pas mal et c'est vrai que le bilan
énergétique
on peut se dire bon on est hyper
rationnel on est tout ce qu'on veut bon
voila quand on sort avec un pieu
énergétique et un envoûtement
bombe 1-2 fait ça pose question alors là
je crois que je vous dois une petite
explication si vous voulez saisir
complètement de quoi parle sophie orange
ici en fait elles ont fait il ya peu de
temps en entretien avec un énergéticien
qui leur a alors proposé de leur faire
leur bilan énergétique et le résultat
n'était pas piquée des hannetons parce
que claire lemaître était visiblement
traversé par un pieu d'énergie tandis
que sophie orange était elle envoûte et
soit par un humain soit par un animal le
diagnostic n'était pas très précis de ce
côté là ça peut prêter à sourire mais en
fait ça souligne surtout la difficulté
qu'il peut y avoir à classifier les
expériences de terrain et donc la
nécessité d'avoir une méthodologie un
peu solide pour pouvoir objective et les
éléments qu'on analyse en essayant de
plaquer le moins possible les idées
préconçues qu'on pourrait avoir sachant
que le rôle de sociologue n'est jamais
d'être normatif expliquer ce qui est
bien ou mal ce qui doit être ou devrait
être mais au contraire de poser un
constat scientifique sur une situation
donnée
quand même beaucoup de questions
méthodologiques aussi sur voilà sur ces
professionnels sans compenser par
rencontrer en fait
parfois on a pu sortir deux arrivées
dans un entretien au sortir d'un
entretien avec effectivement des
rapports au monde mais
qui nous ont semblé mais enfin vraiment
trop éloignés de nos valeurs à se dire
mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très
étrange je comprends pas c'est pas
possible voilà épi et pis c'est pas
l'enjeu enfin l'enjeu il n'est pas là de
il n'est pas de savoir si on adhère ou
pas on n'y pense pas encore une fois
c'est pas ça qui nous intéresse nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est vraiment ce qui
est coincé parce que toi êtes mes skis
et voilà qu'est ce qu'il y a
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme oui il en offre
se rappelle aussi de turckheim qui dit
ben voilà
la tune
c'est une croyance mais elle a des
effets bien réel donc en fait c'est pas
c'est pas la question savoir
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
en tout cas ça produit des effets à quel
effet ça produit et sur qui
qui se saisit de quel ordre voilà et là
on voudrait vraiment travailler à
dégager des indicateurs pour là aussi
pas se dire ben voilà d'un côté on a la
science d'un côté on a des choses plus
ésotériques et en fait c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut faire il faut pas
commencer à appliquer des catégories
mais se dire la prenons des indicateurs
qui mobilise quoi quels sont les termes
qui sont employés donc vraiment partir
de nos clients à 6 ans clients est-ce
que et puis même dans le dans le décorum
afin que la présence de l'ensemble pas
ton sens oui est ce qu'il ya une table
de manipulation et havas de table est ce
que c'est le corps a touché corps n'est
pas touché enfin voilà donc en fait on
revient vraiment
ce que tu pratiques aussi en sept trous
regardez on voit quelques
graphiques ça
on voit donc qu'il est nécessaire de
mettre en place des outils pour aider à
objectiver les pratiques et ne pas se
laisser entraîner par les première
impression qui se dégage du terrain
d'autant plus quand ses impressions
peuvent nous paraître étrange on peut
faire l'erreur de ne pas poser à cette
question et de rester sur des choses
implicite
et surtout une fois sur le terrain on
n'a pas vraiment le temps de niaiser
après un petit café c'est parti pour le
premier entretien de la journée et on
reprend aussi vite la voiture pour se
rendre à l'entretien suivant
donc il va retrouver sur youporn
j'ai donc pu filmer un entretien avec un
hypnotiseur et avec une psychologue mais
l'une des enquêtes et a préféré ne pas
être filmés donc j'ai été obligé
d'attendre à l'extérieur sur la science
mais ça lui sera tout de même que dans
une journée est sociologue il faut
pouvoir être attentif à de nombreux
détails et ça demande une attention qui
peut être assez fatigantes même si les
entretiens sont le plus souvent
enregistrés
doc sophie voilà ces stocks
n'ont finalement cette journée de
terrain était parfaite pour illustrer
l'étonnement et l'imprévu qui peut
jaillir du terrain de fait interroger
les personnels de santé était
initialement un deuxième terrain venu
pallier la difficulté à accepter aux
écoles et la diversité des types de
médecine et finalement étudié illustre
bien le fait que le terrain impose des
problématiques nouvelles qui peuvent
parfois surprendre les chercheurs il
faut également bien avoir en tête que
cette enquête a le gros avantage d'être
financé par l'institut universitaire de
france pendant cinq ans suite à un
projet déposé par sophie orange je dis
que c'est un avantage car elles ont
finalement assez peu de contraintes sur
les rangs du et les attendus ce qui leur
laisse aussi la possibilité de se
laisser surprendre par le terrain et de
suivre des pistes non pris vu
initialement c'était bien sûr si on
avait eu des commanditaires jeu parce
qu'on n'aurait pu explorer ce volet des
écoutes
voilà c'est aussi une liberté et puis
finalement pouvoir aussi faire une
enquête artisanat
sur le temps long
se trouvent du plaisir aussi et
finalement c'est peut-être là dessus
qu'on peut terminer c'est que la
sociologie et bien c'est aussi du
plaisir
aussi qu'on aime et c'est aussi parce
qu'on parlait éclaire le 10 heures il ya
plus en plus de projets de recherche
contrat de recherche avec cette
temporalité qui oblige à déléguer en
fait le travail de terrain à des
personnels souvent précaires en plus
voilà qui font le travail de terrain
nous ce qu'on aime c'est faire du
terrain aussi donc voilà c'est c'est
aller rencontrer les gens et puis après
ben oui faire des petites pauses
voilà là c'est on n'est pas trop mal et
rejoint
cette vidéo est maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout dites
moi ce que vous en avez pensé dans les
commentaires et surtout si ça vous
intéresserait de voir d'autres vidéos un
peu dans le genre où je prends le temps
d'aller expliquer un petit peu les
méthodes de la sociologie j'ai pas mal
d'idées de vidéos que je pourrais faire
pour cette émission dans les polices de
la recherche où j'irai à interviewer
davantage des chercheurs ils parlent de
leurs travaux récents donc dites moi si
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait vous
intéresser en attendant je remercie
évidemment l'université de nantes pour
avoir financé cette vidéo et un merci
tout particulier à tous les intervenants
qui vont accepter que je gêne les
embêter avec les petites questions si la
vidéo est intéressante c'est grâce à eux
n'hésitez pas à voir les liant
description pour voir toutes les vidéos
qui ont été faits dans le cadre du
projet vidéo la bo de l'université de
nantes en attendant moi je vous dis à
très bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
je vous fais de gros bisous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]